[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i am
back from spring break uh a lot of you
guys noticed i took about a week break
from tech except for twitter basically
and uh it was a nice break to have but i
was basically itching to get back to the
whole video making thing the entire time
i was there so i'm back and this is a q
a video now fun fact i used to be
completely against q a videos at all i
feel like you know if someone has a
question i'll just answer it if someone
has a comment i'll just answer the
comment uh but inevitably there's a few
like hot questions that just come in
over and over and over and over again
and no matter how many times i answer
the comment it'll pop up again because
someone else wants to know and they
didn't see it so that's what these q a
videos are going to be for they're going
to be answering the persistent questions
that are pretty much trending i guess uh
that are people asking me on twitter or
on facebook or on google plus or in the
comments section of a bunch of videos in
a row so let's go ahead and get to those
so the first thing is the new samsung
galaxy s5 versus the all new htc one
which one is better
and it's kind of hard to answer that now
because obviously one of those phones
has been announced and the other one has
just been leaked like crazy hasn't
actually been announced yet so what i
will say here is i'm going to wait until
they're both announced to fully judge
both phones side by side but i do plan
on getting a lot of hands-on time and
hopefully a video of the all-new htc one
when it comes out just like i did with
the samsung galaxy s5 that so many
people watched so i'll be getting those
first impressions of that and then of
course we'll get them both full and
house we'll do some comparisons and the
typical in-depth video reviews that you
guys are used to so for now i'm going to
say the htc one looks very promising i'm
obviously a fan of the old htc one and a
lot of you guys have strong opinions
already about the galaxy s5 so i'll say
coming soon for that sort of opinion
number two is a actually question uh
when am i going to change my name from
mkb hd
to mkbuhd
for ultra high definition or 4k uh and
my answer to that is it won't be
actually
when i chose mkbhd i didn't exactly
think of this when i when i first made
the name but hd i like to think of as an
umbrella for all the different high
definition video formats including uh
qhd fhd and inevitably uhd so hd
encompasses all of the high definition
video stuff so it'll be mkbhd for as
long as that's true the third is what is
my daily driver this is a question i get
probably consistently throughout the
year uh so this is an interesting time
because it's kind of the lull after the
holiday season smartphone frenzy uh so
right now my daily driver is
more often than not the nexus 5 the
mkbhd edition so this is the 32 gig
white nexus 5 with that dbrand skin i
talked to you guys about in the update
10.1 video
uh and i use this probably 75 of the
time
i also use a lot uh what i created i
guess a google play edition htc one it's
actually a black htc one with
cyanogenmod installed on it and i also
tend to break out the galaxy note 3 when
i have a heavy road trip or i need a lot
of battery life for the day and i also
almost always have an iphone 5s on me to
take pictures with so those are sort of
the round in the house daily drivers of
mkbhd at least right now that answer
changes like every month the fourth one
is dem notebooks though so i've shown
these they've been like in the
background of a bunch of my videos
recently but i've never actually talked
about them because they're not really
tech related
but these notebooks have gotten a lot of
questions there's actually two of them i
always keep one on my desk and the other
one i took to meet a class
and they have gridded paper on the
inside and some pretty solid build and a
lot of people want to know where they
come from so i went back into my gmail
and found the receipt and this is a
fabric bound planner from dwell a site
that's focused mostly on design stuff
and so there's an orange version and
actually also a black version available
which i did just order because i didn't
realize there was one so uh there's that
and i'm gonna leave a link right below
that like button for you guys to check
it out i will also leave an amazon
equivalent for that for when these
inevitably sell out because a lot of you
guys have been asking where to buy it
i'm assuming you want to buy it so that
link is below the like button so you can
check that out another thing that's
asked behind me is obviously the desktop
wallpapers i use and like where do you
get your desktop wallpapers and lately
i've been rocking this particular one
this one's called ghosts2 it's a facet
designed by justin mallor and he has a
ton of artwork similar to that that i've
shown all on twitter and instagram a lot
of you guys like his work so i'll have
the link to that particular facet in
high resolution if you want to use it as
your phone wallpaper or your desktop
wallpaper or whatever uh he has a ton of
similar work that i'll also link to uh
and it's all pretty awesome stuff and
last but not least is when is the
freaking setup tour project going to be
uploaded to youtube where is it
this is why i usually don't give etas
for videos uh estimated time for arrival
for those of you who don't know a
typical mkbhd review where i control
every single part of it can take
days and maybe even a week to create and
finally upload to youtube so compiling
thousands of clips and first of all
reviewing all those thousands of clips
and sorting them and organizing them and
reviewing them and then editing them and
making them a concise
sort of
viewable format has taken a long time
so for now i will say the status of it
is editing it wasn't editing that
recently actually it took a long time to
watch all 1200 of those videos submitted
but it's editing boom there's your
preview um and i guess i'll say stay
tuned on twitter for more updates of
when exactly that will be dropping
that's going to be a gigantic video so i
hope you guys are excited for that so
yeah that's going to do it for this q a
video again these are just the quick
videos of the trending questions if you
have another burning question feel free
to leave that in the comment section
below you'll see me hanging out
answering comments there
but that's going to do it i'm going to
go back to thinking about all the other
smartphones that we're waiting for in
the next like two weeks the oppo find
seven the new htc one all the phones i
talked about in my last video so
i'll talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching
later peace
[Music]
you